un catalizador es una sustancia que
aumenta la velocidad de una reacción
pero no se consume echemos un vistazo a
la descomposición del peróxido de
hidrógeno el h2o 2 se descompone en agua
y oxígeno
esta reacción puede ocurrir a
temperatura ambiente sin embargo es muy
lenta y para acelerarla necesitamos
agregar un catalizador que en este caso
es una fuente de iones yoduro podemos
usar yoduro de potasio o yoduro de sodio
entonces si agregamos una fuente de
iones yoduro como catalizador eso
incrementa la velocidad de reacción
analicemos el mecanismo para esta
reacción usando el ión yoduro como
catalizador en el primer paso tenemos
h2o2 y el catalizador para producir una
unión hipólito como intermediario
este es nuestro intermediario y también
sabemos que este paso es el más lento
ahora en el segundo paso del mecanismo
tenemos otra molécula de peróxido de
hidrógeno que reacciona con el
intermediario para formar oxígeno este
paso es muy rápido recuerde un posible
mecanismo debe de tener pasos
elementales que al final se puedan
juntar para formar la reacción general
entonces vamos a ver si juntamos todos
los reactivos nos queda h2o2 más y menos
más otro h 22
más o menos
que producen ahora juntemos todos los
productos tenemos h2o
más o menos más h 2 o más o dos más y
menos observen que podemos cancelar el
yoduro porque lo tenemos en los dos
lados eso tiene sentido porque es
nuestro catalizador solamente nos ayuda
a acelerar la reacción pero no se
consume observen que lo usamos en el
primer paso pero se regenera en el
segundo así que al final el catalizador
no se consume ahora vamos con el
intermediario nuestro año ni pollito se
encuentra de los dos lados se cancela
observen que el intermediario se produce
en el primer paso pero después se
consume en el segundo y que nos queda
bueno en los reactivos nos quedan dos
moléculas de h2o 2
h 22 y en los productos tenemos dos
moléculas de agua 2 h2o y una de oxígeno
o 2
esta es la reacción general que teníamos
al inicio ahora también necesitamos que
la ley de velocidad coincida con la ley
de velocidad obtenida experimentalmente
como vimos en el vídeo anterior primero
necesitamos identificar el paso
determinante de la velocidad recuerden
que el paso determinante es el paso más
lento del mecanismo así que el paso 1 es
nuestro paso determinante de la
velocidad de reacción y podemos escribir
la ley de velocidad a partir de este
paso que sabemos es una reacción
elemental y molecular entonces la
velocidad es igual a la constante de
velocidad que para esta reacción
la concentración de h2o 2 que como tiene
un coeficiente de 1 y esta es una
reacción elemental lo podemos usar como
exponente así que nos queda a la primera
potencia por la concentración de lyon
yoduro que también tiene un coeficiente
de 1 así que lo ponemos como exponente
esta es la ley de velocidad tomando como
referencia el paso determinante y
coincide con la que se obtuvo
experimentalmente para la reacción
general entonces este es un posible
mecanismo para la descomposición del
peróxido de hidrógeno veamos como es que
el catalizador nos ayuda a incrementar
la velocidad de una reacción aquí
tenemos el perfil de energía para la
reacción sin catalizador el peróxido se
descompone en agua y oxígeno entonces
empezamos con una cierta
para los reactivos y ya sabemos que en
este punto tenemos el estado de
transición la diferencia entre estos dos
puntos corresponde a la energía de
activación todo esto representa la
energía de activación para la reacción
sin catalizador pero cuando agregamos
una fuente de iones yoduro como
catalizador esto nos permite obtener un
mecanismo de baja energía que además
ocurre en dos pasos la energía de los
reactivos permanece igual pero la
energía de activación disminuye así es
como se ve el perfil de energía cuando
agregamos un catalizador entonces este
es el estado de transición para el
primer paso del mecanismo y observen que
la energía de activación es menor a la
que teníamos originalmente como vimos en
los vídeos anteriores si disminuye la
energía de activación
menta la velocidad de reacción entonces
esto es lo que hace un catalizador este
punto de aquí representa la energía de
los intermediarios que en este caso es
el año y pollo dicto y después tenemos
una segunda energía de activación que
corresponde al segundo paso del
mecanismo esta corresponde al primer
paso y esta es la energía de activación
del segundo paso 2 así que la energía de
activación del primer paso es un poco
mayor debido a que es el paso
determinante y observen que el
catalizador no afecta la energía de los
reactivos ni la de los productos
solamente disminuye la energía de
activación aumentando así la velocidad
de reacción